well hello yeah okay
all right do you so we're just Manning
off the microphone here it's my pleasure
to introduce Annette Patton and the next
speaker is a leash Boudreau is going to
be the handoff at about noon and I will
actually not be able to make that
infection so you'll need to very good
and that's gonna be talking to us about
a few things today the role of research
design and methodology and
evidence-based medicine and informatics
she comes to us with a background in
policy and health services research and
in particular she's looked at the
science determine what works for whom at
what cost and under what circumstances
and she's also examined how our health
system works to support patients and
providers in choosing the right care and
how to improve health through care
delivery she prior positions in the
government which I didn't know about so
I'm curious to hear about but what did
you do for the government anyway I look
forward to your presentation and I think
one other thing I understand that you're
going to plug a survey for the HCI
students we want to know about your
experience with the method methodology
that's been taught in the classes so
please answer the survey when she made
she'll make a plug in then you're gonna
be receiving a link very soon so my
understanding is the objective of this
is you know we're a department that has
maybe two or three parts depending on
how you look at it you know the title
says clinical epidemiology Mattox and
clinical epi and then within medical
informatics there's the health care and
clinical what are the new letters PhD
I'm PCB so if you think about it maybe
we have three parts and then a lot of us
do very different things and when I go
to faculty meetings I don't even know
what all the different faculty do and so
it became apparent that the students
don't know what the faculty do so the
idea of these faculty to four ones was
not necessarily to present a specific
project although we might get to that
but just start by telling you a little
bit about what we do and how we
here so that you know about us and you
might be able to call on us if we can be
a resource going forward so that's
essentially what I'm gonna do I'm going
to tell you a little bit about me and
how my projects that seem very strange
actually I think you kind of fit
together
um so my background is in health policy
initially and then after that a PhD in
health services research and health
services research is a lot like
informatics and what Karen read are two
official definitions in the sense that
you can probably come up with anything
you want to study and fit it into this
so that's the good thing right so as I
say I'm a health services researcher and
a gerontologist because I tend to focus
on Aging and chronic disease but in
health services research you know what
works for whom at what cost and under
what circumstances how to improve the
healthcare system there are so many
topics you can pick that's the good side
the bad side is there's so many topics
you can pick means there's so many
methods and designs right there's no way
you can be an expert in every Theory
every method every design you could ever
use in health services research and I
think that's very similar in informatics
and so this is sort of a stream through
what I'm doing with my work and what I'm
starting with you with teaching as to
how to think about how do we become in
these multi disciplinary fields good
enough to do something useful so that's
what what I've done before I've been
here eight years now which is the
longest job I've ever had because I do a
lot of project-based worked and funded
base externally funded and this position
lets me pull all those things together
but before this I started out as a
legislative aide in Columbus Ohio I
worked in the State House of
Representatives in Ohio and then I went
to grad school in France for a while to
study French because it was fun it had
nothing to do with what I do now
although it's circling around I'll tell
you in a minute
it's important that I now have a
master's in French and then I came back
to New York and I worked for a private
foundation I actually worked for the
Hartford Foundation which does a lot in
aging and then I worked with them with
Common Wealth and with several other
foundations in New York City and then
from there I went to the University of
Minnesota where I got a PhD in health
services research and I worked there in
their aging Center and in that
department and I went to Boise State
where I set up a center for the study of
Aging and a master's certificate in
aging and then went back to New York to
the Bronx I went from Boise to the Bronx
it was actually a poster that said that
once for tw I had died that was great
but I could never get a good picture of
it anyway so I would go back and forth
from Boise to the Bronx and I worked for
a thing called the Center for healthcare
for home care research so that was a
provider based Research Center within
the visiting nurse service and then from
there I did a bunch of consulting for
the VA for a couple of years and then
ended up here so it's been kind of a
tricky path but I think it's interesting
to ask people what kinds of jobs they've
had when you're in a fields like this
informatics and health services that
pulls from so many different ways and
how we all get here is unique so
currently and you'll notice these
numbers add up to more than a hundred
because that's kind of the life of being
faculty so I probably spend I spend most
of my time doing research and most of
that research is through the Pacific
Northwest evidence-based Practice Center
which is your in clinical epidemiology
I'll tell you more about that I've been
doing more teaching originally I did no
teaching at all
so I am doing the this is why it's over
a hundred percent we do teaching in the
School of Medicine that we don't
technically get any time to do but we do
it anyway in interprofessional education
clinical epi and scholarly projects I
work with the medical students to help
design their scholarly projects IPE is
something you guys don't do it's
interprofessional education around
patient safety and yesterday was one of
the sessions there are 52 sessions I was
session 50
you were 48 yeah and it's really kind of
fun so they bring the medical students
all the nursing students the Medical
Physics the pharmacy the laboratory
medicine students together and mix them
all up and then put them in small groups
to go through patient safety some
patient safety training and then there's
a clinical epic track in the medical
student training that several of us are
involved in in the School of Public
Health I currently teach epi of aging
and I also teach I'm developing a
research methods class for mph students
in the non research focus which is
public health practice and then Indy
mice we're going to talk about this it's
a work in progress what it cannot do in
terms of teaching and supporting
students and D mice so the EPC completed
tell you about what I do and I keep an
eye on the time so the EPC has been here
at OHSU for a long time since 97 the e
pcs were founded in 97 we were one of
the original ones there are 13 centers
across the United States who have this
designation of evidence-based practice
in there that's what APC stands for
we're Pacific Northwest we used to be
Oregon but we now have a collaboration
with University of Washington and a
small technical assessment group also in
Tacoma and so we changed our name a few
years ago to become the Pacific
Northwest
EPC we're designated as that by the
agency for Healthcare Research and
quality and we get a tiny little bit of
money and a global contract
they're usually five-year contracts and
then we bid on specific projects so we
get that so they issue calls for
systematic reviews that they would like
we say we write a short proposal there's
a competition but it's only among the 13
so it's sort of inside baseball it's
just really nice if you it's always nice
if you can get connected to people who
have these global contracts because
you're not competing against hundreds of
people you're competing amongst the 13
centers there are other ones like that
here at OHSU david doors been involved
in some through to develop quality
measure
I know that John O'Connor has won with
the state of Oregon where there's only
five people who can compete through
these different contracts so it's just
something to know about anyway we've had
this hasn't been updated but the EPC has
been pretty successful in getting money
and basically what the EPC does is
systematic reviews large usually mostly
to inform practice guidelines and
sometimes to develop standards or
methods we have teams so I've been lead
on several we have librarians some of
whom are in the corner who work with us
a lot we have a lot of research staff
some who've come to come to these
meetings you know most of us are on the
fifth floor on the other side you know
we even have a physical divide and then
we pull people in from other parts of
the university and from other
universities to be on the teams that we
do and technically when I talk to
students I tell them a systematic review
has to have three things the search has
to be comprehensive you have to assess
the studies you can't just tell us about
them you have to there has to be some
how good are the studies and then there
has to be some sort of synthesis it's
not a book report you don't say misters
you know Smith at all said this Jones at
all suck this whether it's a matter
analysis or qualitative so that's the
work we do we take these topics and we
try to look find everything possible it
fits the question evaluate it and
synthesizing and mostly we do the
complete reports but we also do a lot of
other funky things we do some rapid
reviews I've done a couple evidence maps
we do some technical briefs where there
isn't a lot of evidence that has more
sort of talking to stakeholders and then
sometimes we do scoping and you you know
hear about a couple specific ones that I
leash and I are working on later so the
types of projects I've done and this
isn't a complete list it's close but
it's not totally there so some of the
topics I've worked on have been
informatics types topics and Karen and
bill and I have been on these reviews
telehealth consultations tell health
evidence MassHealth an information
exchange and some of them have been more
my subject area so I I let every
on home-based primary care I was part of
a review on pressure ulcers as part of
the review on case management and I'd
rather review on the impact of
geriatricians and then there's other
projects that aren't really my topic
area or even an informatics topic area
but it's more about the methods so we've
been doing a series of three TBI
guidelines traumatic brain injury
guidelines funded through the Department
of Defense passed through from Stanford
University to us to do the reviews and
to facilitate the guideline development
I've done we did a series of reviews one
of which I led that are all to redo the
ems guidelines the surgeons group which
i'm from getting their name the american
congress of college of surgeons i think
it is is going to redo the emergency
medical services guidelines and so
they've commissioned a bunch of reviews
and so i worked on a couple of those
about physiologic predictors and then
every now and then i do a topic i really
know nothing about but focus on the
methods like not invasive testing for
cardiovascular disease coronary artery
disease and then i'm not gonna say
anything about the last 2-3 she's gonna
do it the other work that i've done
added to this next as i am doing some
original research so the EPC work is
synthesizing other people's research
developing guidelines methods and this
is unworking with the oregon rural
practice based research Network which is
a pbrn practice-based research networks
have been around for a while they were a
they're an effort to get research sort
of out into the masses and away from
academic medical centers to set up sites
and networks so that you can do research
outside of sort of the rarefied air of
academic medical centers Oregon has had
one for quite some time seventeen years
if we were the only one that was
exclusively rural through about 2012 and
then 2012 they sort of changed their
charter to include some urban practices
most of these practices are not OHSU
that's fine
the idea and it sets up a network so
that you can do quality and research
projects but Oberon is part of any group
of these it's called Meadowlark the
directors of bird watcher so all the
names have can't have come up to be
Birds you know LJ Fagan physician
faculty do for a long time just
semi-retired he's not allowed to totally
retire and he was just in Mexico trying
to add like two hundred birds to his
list
so I'll hear about that tomorrow I'm
sure but anyway the network of networks
consists of seven of these pbrns five in
the US and two in Canada and about two
years ago I started working with them
and the reason it's so appealing to be
connected to this type of research is
this is a table they made up last year
but you're talking about across to all
seven of them they represent nine
hundred and seventy five primary care
practices with the potential of you know
three point seven million patients so
this is being connected to these
networks makes complicated research
possible and the project I have right
now with them is to evaluate a program
called the serious illness care program
which is to do advanced care planning
with for patients with serious illness
and we're comparing two different models
it's a cluster randomized control trial
we're recruiting 42 practices from those
center networks randomizing them to one
of these two approaches to doing
adaptive planning and then follow it in
patients and clinicians over a year so
that's what I'm the other thing I'm
working on and this is funded through
Khoury so it has a huge engagement piece
which is kind of new for a lot of us I
mean a lot of us have done some
engagement but not structured to the
extent that you really need to do it
with the Cori money so in addition to
the research protocol we have a whole
engagement plan and about how we
incorporate the prm's into this how we
incorporate external stakeholders how do
we have we have patient and family
advisors at three different levels and
the project so at the practice love
at the pbrn level and then we have some
at-large patient and family advisors so
there's a lot of work around engagements
and making sure that there's some sort
of communication across different groups
anyway so kind of what I wanted to say
is across both these types of work what
I really focus on a lot is you know
figuring out what the hammer is given
out right as a methodologist instead of
part of my job is figuring out you know
the nails are all the questions right
then what's the right hammer and can we
figure out what methods and what
theories and what approaches are going
to get us good information and are going
to move us forward there's nothing those
of us in on the policy side I've been a
little bit on the policy side a little
bit on the research side hate more than
when you get to the end of the article
it says we need more research right but
as a researcher we always do that
because it's true
um because one study is rarely gonna
solve the problem which is why I do the
work in the systematically using
guidelines because it's about how do you
take all the studies and pull them
together and make them useful for policy
or practice on the other hand you know
to move the fields forward we have to
work on methods and we have to come up
with what's the best study we can do for
that question at this time given the
resources we've got and we don't want to
squander our research resources so
that's what I think the methodology
piece comes in and so really what I
wanted to ask all of you for a few
minutes so I'm gonna stop talking in a
minute to think about and help me think
about is you know for informatics
research you're an apartment of
informatics I'm faculty in the
Department of Informatics you know how
do you identify questions what kinds of
designs and analysis you know what's
happening in the field what do you need
to know to just be you know a player and
then what needs to what do we need to
push the envelope on what are we not
doing so well in terms of whether it's
training people in informatics or
whether it's proposing research studies
you know what our research studies
answering the questions that people have
in a few
or not and how do we do gather at that
so what I really what we've done or what
we're working on there have been a
couple of I've hunted around for people
who've looked at you know sort of what's
published in JAMA and what analytic
methods are used some someone else
looked at JAMA and then someone else
looked at public health journals and
they sort of give these descriptive
things so you know most stuff is still
pretty low level it's the truth in
what's published in terms of statistical
analysis most studies are still
observational than trials those trials
are expensive so that's not surprising
but how do we get to figure out what US
students and postdocs am I supposed to
say postdocs their fellows when I'm not
supposed to say okay I couldn't figure
out what the terms were this is me not
knowing the training for good yeah well
anyway we're trying to figure out across
the classes what's the research design
and methods needs that students have to
be successful what do you already know
what don't you know how do we figure out
how to train you more efficiently and
how do we you know because there's no
way we can teach you every method you
would ever want so what we're doing is
so now I want to ask people for some
suggestions you also those are people
aren't in the who those of you who are
in HCI not in CV um will get a link to a
survey monkey survey faculty have
already done it we has we asked all the
faculty to further each of their classes
to say whether they cover these things
they cover these things I should say I
think they cover these things this is
just like physicians think they say
thanks to patients we know faculty think
they cover things so we have a list of
things we ask them what they think is
covered in their class and then what
they think they actually make me do
what's an exercise so we want we've
asked some of you to do the same thing
what things have been covered in the
classes you've taken so far and what
things have you actually done some
sort of an active exercise in and then
just a couple quick open-ended questions
you know what haven't you heard about
that you think you know what do you
think you need that you're not getting
are there some topics that are covered
like six and six classes and you know
two would have been enough because we
know I think there's been some effort to
eliminate some implication on some
things related to research and then any
other suggestions because we're trying
to figure out how to do this so let's
start so if you could both now for a
couple of minutes before I hand it over
to I leash get some feedback and then if
do the little survey and then if you
have other suggestions I'm almost always
here on the fifth floor I'm here a lot
and then my email is pretty easy so I'm
just I'm a little confused by something
or always a musical application so what
are the goals so the problem is is that
different fee Docs and post Docs might
have different goals islands for where
they see themselves in the next five
years of the career so from your
perspective as an educator and as the
thinking about the educational training
are you thinking about gardening and
more towards independent careers and
that sort of thing or is it more about
training their skill sets and making
sure that they can you know ask a good
research question and design a study and
answer that question well I think
there's both a floor and a ceiling so
this started out as a question about
what do the PhD students need because
there was a just started out as a very
pragmatic question if there was a
quantitative methods class it was taught
that never could cover everything
everyone wanted and then there were
never enough students and it hasn't been
offered for a while so we're trying to
figure out you know there's a very
practical question what's the
substitution for that quantitative
methods class with PhD students okay
then the broader question is how do we
cover what sort of the minimum research
methods anybody who gets a graduate
degree and informatics should have
that's where you start to get the
competencies and all the different
things and then the middle question is
the people who actually want to do
research whether it's a master's thesis
or whether they want to be involved in
research in their job what's gonna help
them music
so it's a three-part question but I'm
trying to get as much information and
bucket it right the problem there is
that there are dramatically different
skill sets that are needed for all
throttles but there's a floor right each
one sort of builds up I would hope
because the pH is not necessarily okay
well I would hope that the PhD student
has to know that basic bit that we think
all graduate informatics students should
know that the PhD student needs that
plus more and the person in the middle
means that basic fifth plus half of the
more you know that's what I mean I think
there are different levels the different
students need but they're connected at
least or they should maybe build on each
other
well the issue here is that if you're
thinking about independence right a lot
of the things that are predicted for
independence are actually more soft
skills as opposed to hard skills because
there you have to know how to manage
people you have to know how to hire
people you have to know how to UM so I
am trying to focus on the research
component I still think you're true a
lot of my work in research is managing
my team and I do agree that you need to
know how to do those things but we're
also trying to figure out how do we deal
with the technical content so this
really is not necessarily focused on
being successful in informatics but
being successful in the research piece
of informatics and I would argue that
anybody and this is what I said to the
medical students yesterday you know
because some of them are like oh we
don't care about epidemiology
you know which is fine and some of you
know some of those students that in
public health practice are like oh I
don't care about research methods and I
get it but I mean if you're in
healthcare you're gonna be studied even
if you don't do the studying and you
there's a basic amount of literacy you
need to have to understand how you're
being studied if nothing else then I
think you have to understand the
research to be able to interpret it for
your patients and then and hopefully
maybe you're actually going to get
involved but if you never want to do
research as a person in healthcare I
think you at least have to be able to
deal with those first two you got to be
able to explain research to your
patients to the public and you have to
be able to understand
how people are studying you well enough
to speak up if you think they're doing
it wrong you know and I'm a researcher
not a clinician so I want clinicians to
speak up and tell me when we're
designing a study and they're like well
that's the stupidest idea ever but they
have to actually understand it so I'm
happy to yield the floor to any other
current PhDs here I'm coming from a
different similar program at San Diego
the answer the question of on the
clinical side what methods training the
big gap for me was any just data
analysis training there was a lot of
stuff that I had to pick up on the job
of collecting data cleaning data some
basics about information visualization
and that was something that seemed
pretty common across all the students
whether you're dealing with clinical
data any kind of data set and then from
there if you needed machine learning or
fancier methods that was great but that
was the big gap for me is that I just
picked that up working with other people
you never actually like touched to dirty
data and then I'm gonna turn it over to
our leash to actually talk about a
couple actual projects for working on so
I just I'm curious I know that their
research and Academy are and there's
such and private industries and as a
student we don't really know what we
don't know that's for us to be putting
suggestions as to what we want to know
well it can help in a little bit
I totally read said that in meetings it
is hard for students on the other hand
some of you do know like what you think
your thesis topic is or some of you know
what you think you might want to focus
on so I think there's various degrees of
people who know what they don't know and
and you do know at least things you've
heard too many times and things you've
never heard so at least if you could
yeah no I totally get that the survey is
an imperfect thing it's just a way to
incorporate your feedback along with the
feedback from the faculty oh along with
an alumni we did sent we are
see some alums too and then with these
sort of research articles that look at
you know what are the trends in the
field
combined with the competencies that are
required so hopefully all those pieces
of data I could somehow pull together
and come up with something of a plan
which will be flawed
can I add to this a little bit so one of
the things that I was really interested
in when I joined the program is when I
saw that not we have not attached
ourselves to some of the private
industries because most of the research
if you're a research hub how do you
improve the curriculum right you attach
yourself to industries bring people on
to see what is needed in our curriculum
and how we can send our people from here
to those to get you know to develop the
skills that we need for the researching
in the private industries as well so I
was wondering if our curriculum is
looking at partnering with private
industries here look I mean is the best
I mean there's other people who can
answer that better because they do do
outreach to I know that's why we have
that one presentation every year from
Kaiser I don't have we had that this
year yet where Kaiser comes in and they
do that what they look for and
informatics people I know we've had some
discussions and connections with Intel
and you've led a lot of those I think
some of them so the department I don't
know as much about that piece I'll be
honest but I know that there are some
activities and and if you've got better
suggestions take them to Bill other
comments so I'm gonna hand it over to I
wheesh and she's gonna do the second
part of this and this was started
because we actually do a couple of
projects together and this is one of the
examples there aren't a huge number of
examples of people from the two sides of
the department so because she's on the
other side and Alisha's she can tell you
more about her background
just put this around here I'm sorry I
was in usually in clinic at this time so
I don't make it here as often as I'd
like
my name is Louise Boudreau and I am
faculty here but I'm also I came I here
by way of a very sort of roundabout
route I started out as a bench chemist
I thought the HD in biophysics was doing
very very basic science research on DNA
making DNA looking at the structure
using high resolution NMR spectroscopy
then got into imaging when I finished my
PhD I then went to medical school
continued doing research and then I did
a neurology residency and then I did
fellowships in epilepsy and sweet
medicine and then when I came back to
OHSU I came went through the informatics
program and now I'm on staff at OHSU and
the VA and so I've really done
everything from bench very very basic
chemistry to animal research to human
research and have now making forays into
you know areas that I didn't really
expect myself to be in which is health
services research in large part out of
necessity and I'll talk about some of
the projects and as Annette said we are
our collaborations developed very
organically but I think that you know as
I look back now and I'm gonna talk about
three projects they've really helped me
I think probably some of these projects
driving that crazy but she's been very
nice about continuing to participate so
I'm just gonna give you a really broad
overview of some of these
so you can get a flavor of I think the
important thing here is part of this is
so people can find out what various
people in informatics are doing but also
how I think and why I think our
collaboration is really helpful at least
from my perspective okay I'm gonna talk
about three projects some of you had me
in class may have heard of some of these
and I've got sitting co-investigators in
here for various things so the first one
is optimizing va sleep care this I can't
one sleep medicine cohorts and then the
other one is an area that I've been
working in for probably two and a half
decades since I was a graduate student
and that is in aerospace physiology and
you know what that shouldn't be
epidemiology neurocognitive evaluation
of fitness to fly
well there should have been a colon but
anyway so let's start with the problem
in the first project so here's a graph
of access to VA sleep care services and
I'm not going to go into there's a lot
of details about how we deliver care
what kind of care they deliver but the
gist here is you can see in 2012 we're
down here and this happens to be new
patients referred into the VA nationally
and in fiscal year 2007 you know we've
gone from just over a hundred thousand
to three hundred and fifty thousand and
that's every year new patients there's
lots of things that go in to sleep care
they involve you know one of our most
common diagnosis sleep apnea that one
involves sleep testing and then it's
positive giving people equipment and
following them there's insomnia often
patients who have sleep apnea have other
sleep problems they're very common in
the population so it's not a single time
like we see them and then they go off
and their cure
and everything's done this is chronic
disease management so I could pretty
much insert anything we do in sleep and
the curves gonna look like this I could
insert the number of sleep studies I
could insert the number of you know
encounters in the system for sleep care
and if you look in two thousand up to
now the curves are gonna look like this
they're really crushing oh that's just
that percent change increase yes sorry
that's so basically the the point here
is thanks for a spherical is sleep is a
relatively new field compared to
cardiology pulmonology neurology and it
many there Soviets that don't offer any
sleep care so what we've seen is as the
field has matured and as people are more
aware of sleep disorders we get more and
more referrals there's also evidence for
a number of reasons that the prevalence
is increasing in the population but
anyway so what we have here is we
started out with very small operations
not at every Medical Center generally
understaffed and then we've dumped a
huge number of patients into the system
they also notice we've got the conflicts
starting in 2003 that had infused a huge
number of younger patients so what the
problem we have is a huge number of
patients needing care and very limited
resources
there aren't enough sleep physicians in
the system to or in the country who are
trained in sleep to take care of them
and the other problem is even if we had
that using traditional care models we
would completely break the bank like we
can't care for this volume of patients
using the methods we use thus far so
just to get a general sense there 20
million veterans in the u.s. 9 point 1
million are enrolled and to get some
kind of care through the VA 58 percent
of those patients are located
early and we have about 1.2 million that
have been diagnosed thus far with sleep
apnea and based on pretty good data we
suspect that up to 35% of veterans are
at risk for sleep apnea so maybe we've
diagnosed sixty percent who are out
there that's assuming that the
prevalence remains steady which it
doesn't look like it is so the bottom
line is this is what the curves look
like and it's probably not going to
change anytime soon so that's the
problem it's this huge sort of scope the
other thing I thought was very
interesting I've gotten slides from a
colleague that I work closely with dr.
Sarmiento in San Francisco but this is a
VA map showing where VA sleep flats are
this is in Lao so you notice the number
I gave you 58% of the 9.1 million
veterans are rural II located but look
at where the sleep labs are we've got
this huge chunk of territory basically
you know between the Midwest and the
west coast it doesn't have a lot going
on and that's another huge problem how
do we get care to people so what are the
challenges there's a lot of challenges
that we're working on but they fall into
two bins so the first is how do we
measure what we're doing and let me give
you a very concrete example of something
that every program in the country was
struggling with you know up until fairly
recently so I'm in our lab a number of
years ago and a good administrator with
clinical history comes up and says I'm
really concerned about this problem
you guys did 750 sleep studies last year
we just ran the numbers and it looks
like you're over staffed
now again
the curve I just showed you so there
they're telling us you know right around
in here that we're over we're under
we're over staffed I'm like okay there's
a disconnect here but I keep listening
and and you know fence when she tells
her you did 750 sleep studies last year
I'm like well that's the first problem
we did mm here's our logbook this point
we're still using log books and we did
2,000 sleep studies and she said we
can't use logbook data we have to go by
the data in the system and I'm like but
the data in the system
you know is capturing 40% of our
workload and so this happened over and
over again I have colleagues in other
places who would come in to work and
find out that staff had been pulled
because they were over resourced and
we're all like what planet you know are
are these administrators living on and
where is this data coming from it's what
I call imaginary numbers so they kept
coming to us with numbers that
absolutely made no sense and so a lot of
us started asking questions about where
are these numbers coming from how are
they coming how are you getting them and
that's when I became involved in another
area never thought I would see myself
which is coding and systems and how do
we capture workload so we've done a lot
of work in that area and actually
shifted the conversation so in our
region or vision in 2012 we rolled out
revised coding for sleep so part of the
problem had been that sleep services
were offered in a number of different
departments pulmonary neurology mental
health and they would always get coded
for for whatever department so when
people would pull national numbers they
would just get highly variable picture
they weren't capturing a lot of the data
but just for our region alone the
Northwest region in the space of one
month in 2012 our workload went up by
29%
now obviously didn't go up by 29% that's
how much we were missing when we rolled
this out nationally went up by over a
hundred percent one colleague at another
institution found out that they weren't
capturing any of his
workload and his workload in one month
went up 700 percent and as he likes to
joke I'm not sure what I was doing for
80 hours a week prior to that but
apparently nothing according to the
administration so that's really really
helped us is understanding how they
generate the data we still have problems
and it's a lot more complicated than I
ever envisioned but that's changed our
conversation a lot just being able to
capture our workloads so that's that's
been a huge issue the other is how do we
develop better care models so the
problem as I mentioned is the
traditional model of care as you go see
a sleep physician then maybe we send you
for an in lab sleep study which involves
having to come in a two to one ratio
with attack we study you one or two
nights in the lab it's incredibly
expensive and then we give you a CPAP
machine which is at least 350 dollars
and then we follow you presumably for
life and that's just sleep apnea so
there are a lot of emerging models
things like can you do electronic
consults which we have in the VA can you
send people home or mail them home sleep
apnea testing equipment which is getting
a lot more sophisticated better and then
can you use telehealth video into other
VA centers that don't have facilities or
video into the patient's home we now
have so we're experimenting with all of
these models because it's absolutely
clear you know we're already drowning
under the volume we have and it's only
gonna get worse because remember every
year we're adding a huge number of
patients to our system we're not even
getting to the diagnosis let alone
managing long-term all of these patients
so it's very very clear that we have to
use these models most of us within the
VA have been using them for a while the
problem is we don't have any data that
it's equivalent we think it's equivalent
but it really is a problem we the burden
is really on us to show because we're
operating in many cases outside of
practice guidelines for you know for
sleep medicine so there's really a
burden that we collect data at the point
of care and that we try to make some
quality assessment on whether these
models are equivalent and even modest
you know mild changes can cut huge
savings for the VA so last year the VA
spent 250 million dollars on CPAP
equipment so if you just make small
adjustments you really can save a lot
and care so this VA system issues on a
high level pretty much you can take
pretty much every topic in Bill Hersh's
introduction to clinical informatics and
there's an issue related to it and then
some we've got data capture issues at
the point-of-care we do a specialized
templates that we've deployed at least
in the northwest and then starting to to
push them out to other sites where we
can actually have people enter data as
the providing care but specific preset
items can be put into the centralized
clinical data warehouse at the VA for
easy you know easy retrieval and they're
not only about what we're doing they're
about care pathways which is what we
really need information data siloing so
the VA even though it's the largest sort
of managed health care system in the
country it does have a centralized
database the clinical data warehouse and
so you would think that the data we
would get out of it would be more
consistent and in fact that is not true
a lot of the data siloing occurs because
people are using different interfaces to
pull the data and what we're finding is
that the interfaces are making all sorts
of assumptions that often are correct
and people are coming up with different
numbers we also have different pots of
care so everything all care that gets
done within the VA actually goes into
this clinical data warehouse
but care that is outsourced does not
choice care all these different programs
prosthetics care is in a different
database so we have the data siloing I
already talked huge coding issues
workload tracking right now they can't
track physician workload for sleep care
and they said it's probably not going to
happen anytime soon because the system's
just not set up to do it and they care
delivery models which I talked about we
have telehealth we actually have a
virtual care path program that we're
piloting with rural patients so a lot is
going on but there's a lot of work to be
done so the project that Annette and I
are working on together as this office
of rural health telemedicine project and
it's basically you know a large national
grant over three years to improve care
delivery and what we built out here in
Portland is a lot of the data analytics
so there's lots of good data analysts in
the VA but if they we need sleep
specific data expertise because a lot of
times people are pulling numbers and as
they said making all sorts of incorrect
assumptions and it's very very messy so
we really became convinced that we
needed sleep specific expertise so we
could make sure people who are making
decisions both on the local regional and
national level are using real numbers
which has not happened in the past and
then there's lots of data that needs to
be management be managed and as I
mentioned the sleep expertise so again
it's a very large project and we've
built a little local data analytics team
of which and that is a critical part of
so these are just some of the
yes but everybody everybody contributes
but Connors our data analyst and he's
done a great job and he in the ten
months he's been working with us he's
learned all the different ways you can
pull data and have it not be meaningful
meaning he's not doing that but he's
trying to track down why did people come
up with numbers because we have
knowledge about the different programs
and so we can look at data and go like
that
that's not even ballpark and so then we
have to dig and figure out you know why
do two centers that do the same volume
of care and one last month said they
delivered no care and one you know had
you know 500 consoles so and it's very
interdisciplinary so we work closely
with teams at the VA in San Francisco
but also with with there are eight
different centers involved in this in
this team so there's a lot of the
interdisciplinary work so that is that
project attempted in a nutshell and the
other two projects I'm just going to
talk about very briefly so the other one
is a sleep and circadian Health Project
and this really is this came out of
there was a RFA by the National Heart
Lung and Blood Institute for new cohorts
and so they are looking for you know
what do we need in new cohorts and heart
lung blood disease and sleep gets placed
under that Institute as I mentioned
sleep is a new field so we don't have as
good long-term epidemiologic data and
we're a smaller field so one of the
issues we've struggled with is how do we
compete or work with these large other
fields like cardiology to justify you
know why we need a sleep specific cohort
a lot of the cohorts to date have been
built into other studies cardiology
studies you know as subcomponents
so we were really thinking about this as
a field and part of this was done as
part of the sleep research Network which
I've been very involved in and that's a
consortium of researchers at ctsas
around the country and others so what we
were able to do is we were able to get
some end of your money from the VA at
the end of the fiscal year sometimes the
VA has pots of money that it can push
out and it usually gets you know they
say we've got this pot of money for a
hundred thousand or two hundred thousand
and if you can give us a proposal and
take the money and do something with it
before the end of the fiscal year like
in the next two weeks you can have it so
we were lucky enough and a lot of
colleagues and informatics helped us
sort of get that money over here and
attach it to the contract that we have
for the previous project looking at what
what do we know about sleep cohorts
today and so the purpose of this was we
that the sleep community is decided we
are going to put in an application in a
year and a half for it's the last date
we can submit for it but there was a lot
of discussion about well how do we
figure out what we really need how do we
figure out what would be the highest
impact cohort so one of the things based
on my work with and that I'd suggested
was could we do some kind of systematic
review the analysis that looked at what
cohort studies have been conducted in
the past or in progress in a very sort
of rigorous fashion and what high
priority topics haven't been covered and
we think need to be covered and it
really focuses on how do we pull
together a team and look at what's been
done try to figure out what's that
impact on other fields because anything
we do in sleep because we are a small
field a new field we really have to
frame
in terms of what we also contribute to
other fields how do we improve
cardiovascular health
pulmonary health by improving aspects of
sleep so these were some of the
questions and the idea was to get
everybody together provide some
structure to how we think about what
we've done what needs to be done and so
we were able to get this ten month
contract and here as they mentioned
where the gaps identified gaps figure
out what tools we already have that we
could use for a cohort study and
organize and mobilize key stakeholders I
think this is something that's hugely a
value is the whole process but an that
talked about where you bring
stakeholders together you ask questions
you frame those questions is hugely
valuable and it provides a way for you
to come out at the end with some really
concrete answers to some of your
questions and one of the things that
it's been especially helpful for me and
is how to frame questions I come to her
all the time and say this is what I this
is what I want and she'll just think
about it and say wow is that really what
you want or do you want this and it's
always the way she reframed it so a lot
of times we think we know what we want
but we haven't asked it in a fashion
that is really a productive way to
answer it so that's where she's been
especially helpful again team effort
lots of people in in this room and that
Chandler Francis we have colleagues at
UCSF the sleep research Network
maybe Sarmiento is also on this one and
we've got people on the panel from
academic centers around the country
industry and and patient reps so really
it's it's infrastructure to get people
going and then the last one I'm going to
just say for a few minutes
it's neurocognitive evaluation of
fitness to fly so what's the problem
so the problem is there's a lot of
aircraft activity in the world right now
we have 5,000 aircraft in in the air at
any given time
ten million scheduled pasion passenger
flights a year in the country this is
from the FAA two million passengers fly
every day in and out of US airports two
million and then a lot of different US
airports so you know aviation is the
safest mode of transportation last year
there were about 37,000 but a dateable
motor vehicle accidents and only 350
fatal aviation accidents and most of
those are not commercial that's sort of
recreational pilots small general
aviation so it's incredibly safe mode of
flight but there's a reason for it it's
incredibly regulated it wasn't always
safe part of the the current regulatory
structure we have came out of having a
lot of plane crashes and the 50s where
you were losing a lot of aircraft with a
lot of human life so there's been a lot
of effort on that so the problem is and
I'm gonna mainly address this applies to
all branches of sort of aviation general
aviation the recreational pilot but I'm
gonna just focus on the commercial
airline pilot so what happens if you
have a pilot who's been flying 20 years
has a lot of experience
maybe he has a mini-stroke at CIA or
maybe he gets blinding migraine
headaches or maybe he's had a mild
traumatic brain injury what happens
after they recover from that how do you
get them back to flying what do you need
to know about their neurocognitive their
neuropsychological function because if
you're in a cockpit it's an incredibly
complex set even though you're
incredibly well trained there's a lot
you have to keep strength there in in
larger aircraft there's at least two
pilots but not in every aircraft and so
what happens
you know what do you need to know about
that pilot to ensure that they can go
back and function at the level that they
have to to keep aviation as safe as it
is and we really worry with neurologic
issues how do we predict or how can we
figure out what the risk is if someone's
gonna have an acute event in the cockpit
that could be fatal not only for them
but for the people they're flying so
it's really a balance between safety and
and loss you don't want to be grounding
a bunch of pilots who have a huge amount
of expertise they all end up going on
disability you may ground them so you
ground them in their 50s and they still
have another decade potentially of
flying so it's it's an incredibly
contentious topic one that is threatened
to boil over the policy into Congress
out of the hands of people who sort of
do the evaluations so as part of my work
with the earth space Medical Association
looking at how we can do more systematic
reviews and aerospace medicine one of my
actually one of my mentors who's worked
a lot in this brought this topic and
said can we get some kind of systematic
review going so we at least know where
we are where we're starting from because
no one's really happy with the process
and so really in this case the
advantages of our collaboration I'm not
going to go into the details of what
that project entails and why it's so
contentious but but the issue is there's
really people are at loggerheads about
it you know if you talk to the pilot
groups there they're concerned with the
length of time it takes they're
concerned with people unnecessarily
getting grounded and people who fly fly
not because it's just sort of a job you
show up to they're passionate about it
and so this just makes them nuts we're
messing with their livelihood and I got
way they get so passionate about it but
on the other hand you have to worry
about people like do you want to be the
person who certifies someone to fly who
then you know like crashes a plane with
300
people on it so it's trying to get this
balance and one of the things that doing
the systematic review has been so
helpful for it's getting everybody than
the table so to my knowledge this is the
first time a group of pilots researchers
regular individuals who do regulation
from the FAA are all at the same table I
mean people do talk across but in a
formal way this has really provided us
with a vehicle to get everybody together
and say look we're gonna we just want to
look at our data let's just ask the
question what do we know about the test
that we use for a neuro cognitive
evaluation for fitness to fly what don't
we know so we can figure out what we
need to do to make at least the science
behind it better so we're really
focusing on the science but it really
has provided a structure for us to start
building some collaborative work and to
identify key gaps and frame questions
it's really important in this day and
age of limited funding to be able to
show potential funders that you've
really been thoughtful about how you've
identified your gaps and one of the
problems I'll put it in quotes of
aviation medicine in aerospace medicine
is we're almost a victim of the fact
that flying is so safe they're like
what's the issue
flying's already super safe like where's
the where's the problem we've got more
pressing issues that we need to spend
research on so we really have an
obligation to highlight what we've done
and what we need to do so again a huge
team effort
Anette Cynthia and Tamara are the RAS on
it and this stakeholder panel that
involves a number of people from you
know researchers academics pilot reps
regulatory but as as our stakeholder
panel
so in closing really my take-home
message as a researcher you know engage
your colleagues and evidence-based
medicine early in your research because
what I found is they've really helped me
get clarity on what we need to do
rather than I think we think a lot of
evidence-based medicine is occurring
after research has been done you know
then you bring people in to help you
synthesize everything I think that's
actually backwards
they certainly serve a huge function
there but I think we need to engage them
very early on and that has been
incredibly helpful as we thought about
the VA sleep project and we're starting
to write grants to try to show that what
we're doing is at least equivalent to
the traditional care model it's been
incredibly helpful to have her help us
frame these questions in an answerable
way and keep us focused on what are the
most important issues so that we come
out at the other end which is something
that we can use clinically so engage
them early on and often and that's all I
have and if there any questions for
Annette or me
I'm really intrigued by the stakeholder
groups that you were able to get
together and just wonder if you'd give
us a little more information about the
consensus process like how do you when
when everybody's such different places
how do you then decide what actually
moves forward in your research right so
I don't know if this is a quiet I'll
answer it a little bit but then I'm
gonna hand it to Annette and so I'll
give you the example of the aviation one
so I I worked in that field I know a lot
of people in it I work you know very
involved in the aerospace Medical
Association so I knew the players that
had to be there and I knew who to talk
to so a lot of what I did was who are
the most reasonable people that we can
get to the table who are key I mean it's
not that we don't want we really wanted
a true sample of differing views but you
also have to like Who am I gonna get
there who can commit to working through
some difficult things and being on calls
with people that they're not used that
they're used to being at loggerheads
with versus actually collaborating with
them at least on a official you know
sort of way so part of that sort of
understanding the field and figuring out
who can we can we use for this but a lot
of for me has been I could have gotten
the group together I wouldn't have known
what to do with them though how to move
it forward and that's where I think the
evidence based practice structure has
been so incredibly helpful because we
can bring in this neutral third party
you know who's a methodologist and say
here's the published process and we're
just going to follow that and then I'm
going to turn it over to Annette to make
some some comments and we're at the time
and I'll just yeah it varies by project
so this project had a very political
component to getting the people together
so not just to get their input to make
sure the question was right but to also
get their buy-in at the beginning so
that the product will be useful which is
different than some other projects where
it's much more the stakeholders provide
sort of technical support or versus like
the pakora funded work where
the stakeholders really shape how we're
rolling out the implementation of the
advanced care planning so it really
varies depending on the project a lot
and it's a lot of work which is sort of
the this idea that researchers like sit
in the office all by themselves at a lab
all by themselves doesn't really fly
anymore and it's really hard to get any
research funded that way
so sort of figuring out how to do that
stakeholder engagement is one of those
skills that might be on the list okay
great thank you
[Applause]